[Musica]
[Risate]
wow va pensiero sull'ali dorate un brano
meraviglioso di giuseppe verdi
mamma mia che musica pazzesca ragazzi
musica classica
attenzione questo un brano incredibile
avete sentito che melodia incantevole
accompagnata da delle armonie
altrettanto meravigliose romantiche c'è
qualche cosa temo
[Musica]
beh quando arriva questa nota veramente
sono nel condimento più totale musica
veramente cosa m maiuscola che non ha
bisogno di grandi cose dice tutto da
sola però purtroppo oggi questa musica
non si ascolta più o si ascolta molto
poco probabilmente è rimasta musica per
addetti ai lavori musica per musicisti o
musica per pochi affezionati
pensate che io ho un passato anche da
chitarrista classico o un passato dove
ho studiato veramente tanti generi
musicali e ho fatto anche chitarra
classica ma in realtà ho cominciato ad
amare questo genere nel momento in cui
me ne sono allontanato incredibile
paradossale ma è andata veramente così
ho cominciato a capire che cosa mi stavo
davvero perdendo e questo però è un
peccato
quale potrebbe essere il problema per
cui la musica classica oggi non viene
più ascoltata e un genere di nicchia
allora io mi sono messo lì ho provato a
fare un po di ragionamenti e ho trovato
un problema secondo me un problema
semplice ma molto importante la
lunghezza i brani di musica classica
sono troppo lunghi mannaggia troppo
lunghi una semplice sonata di beethoven
per dire può durare dieci minuti un
quarto d'ora una sinfonia di mozart 20
minuti ma io come faccio avere tutto
questo tempo per ascoltare venti minuti
di musica e attenzione notate bene non
20 minuti in cui faccio le pulizie ma
venti minuti in cui devo essere molto
attento a che cosa succede perché quella
musicali e ricca di meno di essi mi
perdo qualcosa mi sto perdendo veramente
quasi tutta l'essenza del pezzo
al che ho detto ok a questo è un
problema ed è un problema da risolvere
ma attenzione il problema non è la
musica
il problema non sono gli ascoltatori
il problema sono i musicisti
il problema sono io sono io che devo
risolvere il problema non siete voi che
dovete risolverlo
sono io che vi devo servire su un piatto
d'argento la musica classica
questo è il vero vero importante passo
da fare anche perché abbiamo un problema
grosso
abbiamo un antagonista veramente forte
dall'altra parte la musica classica come
dicevo dura 15 minuti 20 minuti
la musica moderna un format aggressivo e
cattivo mannaggia in tre minuti ci dice
tutto in un minuto
in realtà ci dice davvero tutto quello
che serve insomma a una canzone
nei due minuti restanti sostanzialmente
ripete la stessa cosa
pertanto qui dobbiamo capire come fare a
fare una manovra che ci permetta di
portarci a essere aggressivi come la
musica moderna
allora io che cosa faccio mi sono
inventato due operazioni per riuscire a
fare questa cosa qua la prima operazione
è quella di cominciare a prendere un
pezzo di musica classica scegliere il
minuto del brano di musica classica che
mi piace di più
lavorerò su quel minuto in modo tale che
mi sono avvicinato notevolmente al
format moderno
dopodiché seconda operazione gli faccio
il cambio d'abito c'è che cosa lo
spoglio dei suoi vestiti formali quindi
della sua giacca della sua cravatta
della sua camicia che siamo abituati a
vedere da tempo e lo rivesto di abiti
nuovi abiti informali casual una giacca
di pelle un jeans anche strappato
guardate i miei stampati una t shirt e
per fare questo o tre segreti tre step
il primo step l'analisi della melodia
cioè imparo il brano è semplice scontato
ma la prima cosa devo imparare la
melodia nella sua semplicità
vi faccio un esempio se vi faccio
sentire questo
[Musica]
ok vi ho fatto sentire una melodia che
conoscete davvero tutti secondo step
prendo questa melodia gli aggiungo una
parte molto semplice di armonia che
cos'è l'armonia l'armonia quella parte
semplice dell'armonia il basso cioè
cerco di mettere una linea di basso una
linea molto basic per esempio
6 passo de roi
sopra questo basso li rimetto la melodia
che abbia fatto sentire prima ea questo
punto o una parte bassa una parte alta
cioè ho creato una sorta di casa
virtuale ossia immaginatevi una casa che
è formata ovviamente dalle fondamenta
quindi garage e cantina e poi da un
tetto che la mia melodia quindi il basso
sotto la melodia sopra a questo punto vi
faccio sentire cosa ne viene fuori
[Musica]
bello eh
caspita ho già una bidimensionalità del
pezzo attenzione mi fiondo al terzo step
il terzo step è quello dell'armonia che
cos'è l'armonia l'armonia due o tre note
che si sovrappongono tra di loro e mi
danno la sensazione del colore della
musica basso
meno di a
aromi a accordo
wow ecco a me interessava arrivare qui
perché qui ho veramente il modo di
attaccare il pezzo è di cominciare
davvero a fare il cambio d'abito cioè
prendo l'armonia questo accordo molto
semplice e puro la maggiore lo sporco o
magari una nota blues
avete sentito no ok poi vado avanti
altro accordo che non c'era in mozart
per caricando un parliamo di questo
questo qua è un accordo jazz
ma nel 1700 mica esisteva il jazz eppure
questo è un accordo straordinario
moderno ma che non c'entra con magari
c'entra con pino daniele
ma sicuramente da un con mozart a questo
punto fatta questa manovra
faccio l'ultima manovra veramente
impattante che è quella del tempo cioè
il tempo che talento moderato morbido
diventa veloce aggressivo e che
riassumerei uno solo termine c'è rock e
a questo punto io li vado a colpire
veramente nel segno
[Musica]
ok e quindi gli ho dato landi rocca a un
pezzo classico velo faccio sentire più o
meno completo per avere un'idea di che
cosa ho combinato su questo an klein
nachtmusik di mozart
[Musica]
vado avanti
ecco qua roberti aiuto
[Musica]
rock
l'usa
[Musica]
eccetera eccetera ok quindi ho dato un
pochino unan di rock a questo pezzo che
ovviamente rock non era la stessa cosa
l'ho fatta nel pezzo alla fine con la
regina della notte sempre di mozart
meglio conosciuta come
[Musica]
sentite cosa ho combinato
e daje
[Musica]
eva il gran finale
un po di virtuosismo
[Musica]
ecco qua sono arrivato questo era quello
che interessava me arrivare qui partire
dalla e arrivare qui ed è quello che
invito a fare tutti voi cioè vi lascio
con un invito a casa andate a sdraiarmi
sul vostro divanetto bello comodo vi
mettete su un bel disco di musica
classica
chiudete gli occhi mi raccomando e
provate voi a rivestire il brano che
state ascoltando con abiti nuovi
un po come ho fatto io in realtà poi ho
fatto questo lo traduco sullo strumento
voi potete farlo con la vostra mente con
la vostra fantasia
qui mi date sfogo veramente alla vostra
immaginazione e fatevi trasportare dalla
bellezza della musica classica spogliate
la e rivestitela come più vi piace
grazie
[Musica]